you know YouTube can be confusing and
when I was just starting out on YouTube
I made a ton of mistakes that I wish I
would have had some information at the
start so that I could have avoided the
pain and frustration that just not
knowing what I didn't know caused so in
this video I'm gonna be bringing on two
special guests and we're all going to be
processing the things we wish we knew
before starting YouTube and we actually
have 13 different things so buckle your
seat belt hit the like button if you're
fired up and get ready for today's Deep
dive training about getting more views
growing your subscribers and really
learning some of the things that nobody
else is talking about when it comes to
growing a YouTube channel but hey if
we're just meeting my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel yes
it does and this is the think media
podcast Channel and I'm fired up because
today we are learning from two special
guests that are absolutely crushing it
on YouTube the first is Mary's nest and
she is going to to be she has almost a
million subscribers has a channel I'm
going to bring her on in just a second
talking about the traditional cooking
for the modern pioneer and we'll look at
her Channel but Mary how's it going oh
hi Sean thank you for having me I'm
doing well
I'm so fired up you are here can you
just tell us a little bit about how long
have you been on YouTube what is your
Channel all about and just a brief
snapshot of your story
well I started making videos in July of
I had taught traditional cooking in my
kitchen for years and when I became an
empty nester I needed something else to
do and my husband and son encouraged me
to put my cooking classes online and I
teach as I said traditional cooking I
teach how to make bone broth and
ferments cultured Dairy sourdough things
like that and over the years it's kind
of broadened to include other things
like home remedies with herbs and
stocking the pantry and so on and so
forth and just all about basically you
know how to make as much as you can
homemade like being a modern pioneer in
the kitchen
so amazing and you've gone from zero to
849 000 subscribers and so I can't wait
to get into your tips in just a second
but next up we have Dr Andrea furland
and uh she's got an incredible Channel
talking all about chronic pain and has
had some incredible Open Door
opportunities because of her Channel
almost to 500 000 subscribers Dr Andrea
welcome to the show today how are you
doing thank you I'm doing great thank
you so much for inviting me here can you
tell us a little bit about your story a
little bit about your channel and the
mission and vision of what you're doing
over here yes
yes of course so I am
another Toronto
and I work in the pain clinic in
downtown Toronto and I see lots of
people with chronic pain and most of
what we do shown for chronic pain is
education and I spent a lot of time
talking talking to my patients telling
them about you know the diagnosis that
they have and then what they have to do
and then sometimes I have to go on their
bed and show them how to do the exercise
that I want them to do and so I wasn't
spending a lot of time with my own
patients and I decided I started in 2019
with a simple cell phone
uh recording myself at home and said I'm
going to put myself on YouTube just for
my own patients and uh whatever I tell
them in the clinic I'm going to record
and it seems that it's not only my
patients they're like this but a lot of
other people
yeah that's incredible and I actually
personally have dealt with some chronic
pain issues repetitive strain injury we
were just talking off camera about you
know nerves originating from my neck and
hand pain so you're such a blessing to
hundreds of thousands of people but of
course both Mary and Dr Andrea we all
start at zero and you guys started at
the very beginning
um we have 13 tips that you kind of
submitted ahead of time and we've
Consolidated those into some actionable
points I want to start with you Dr
Andrea the first tip and then we'll go
to Mary on this one is YouTube has some
advantages over other social media
platforms talk about what you've
experienced in building your influence
on YouTube specifically and what you
mean by that yeah I be on Twitter since
2009 2010
and I tried to grow on Twitter and then
on Facebook and Instagram I wanted to
have like a a place where I could put a
my knowledge it seems that I have so
much knowledge in my head and I wanted
to teach people
and I I couldn't grow on Twitter it's uh
you know they don't allowed this it's
not a platform for education and then
the other option would be blogs but I
would say my patients don't have
patience because chronic pain affects
your concentration you are tired I don't
think they would be reading if I put all
of this information in a book or a Blog
so I decided to put in a video I think
video people can watch and and
understand what I'm saying so it was
fantastic for what I wanted to educate
people who have chronic pain much better
than the other platforms that I tried
before
and one of the things you mentioned was
YouTube's different because people can
find content that you have literally
posted years ago you have videos that
are years old that are still getting
views uh right now your channel is
getting 1.3 million views a month 14 000
new subscribers congratulations about on
that and you know here at think media we
talk a lot about ranking videos and I
love this this is actually a feature
from bid IQ that allows us to see videos
that are three years old that are still
getting five views an hour your
exercises for neck pain it's a
three-year-old video and five people not
only are getting views and you got the
ad revenue and everything else but
you're also getting
um of course impact you're changing
lives and I'm gonna bring Mary on
because Mary you've been experiencing
this as well like what made you choose
YouTube why do you like YouTube and you
know it being different have you had do
you have some videos that are older that
continue to get views
oh definitely some of my very earliest
videos are some of my most active that
really do continue to get views uh I
started with putting out the first 15
videos all about like making basic
things under the umbrella of things that
I teach like the bone broth and those
are the most popular and they continue
to get uh they continue to be searched
and come up in Search and people watch
them I I will still answer comments on
those videos even
yeah that's amazing like we're seeing
here this bone Bath recipe from five
years ago gets 34.8 views per hour which
is the dream this is why we all love
YouTube because other social media
platforms are cool and Instagram's a
cool place to engage with other people
and uh whatnot and of course we do love
all the platforms but YouTube has a
better Advantage than all of them
because it's the only platform where
your content lives forever which brings
us to number two success on YouTube
takes hard work and patience we're going
to start with you Dr Andrea uh you
mentioned even at times feeling emotions
like wanting to quit break that down of
what you've learned for what it really
takes to build a YouTube channel
oh yeah it takes hard work it's not easy
and um you have to learn a lot of things
and thanks God for VRA and think think
media because uh I don't know where I
learned those things and I read your
books the first and the second edition
but uh you know it's hard work because
you have to practice you have to try
and then sometimes you put I put a lot
of effort in one video and I say this is
going to hit I love this one and then
nothing really exciting happens I get
views but I get people unsubscribing and
like when I you know YouTube shows you
how many people subscribe for each video
and then I say oh my God I lost 20
subscribers with that video what
happened
so it's disappointing I said hi I'll
stop doing this and just leave things
there but then I go and I read the
comments and people being helped and
people all over the world
um you know really thinking what I do
and sharing my knowledge and that's what
gives me energy to keep doing what I do
but um patience is key in this um like I
had videos that they did nothing they
were quite very few views for 18 months
and then boom one day I see what's going
on I'm getting a lot of comments on this
video
then I know people are watching more and
then I go and see the analytics for that
video and it's a vertical line like this
I don't know why I have no idea but
once in a while that happens that
happens with some of my videos on diet
like the vitamin D vitamin
uh I think that the anti-inflammatory
diet was also like that like a surprise
a long time after it was published
I love that and it's I've seen that same
thing happen for me where it's something
about there's results goals and there's
action goals results goals are like I
want to get a thousand subscribers
action goals or I'm just going to keep
posting videos and I'm going to let the
results speak for themselves and maybe
it doesn't happen as fast as you want it
to happen but as you keep posting videos
a couple break out and then the
byproduct is the result that you wanted
to set a goal for and Mary I know that
you have some experience with this as
well when we were connecting with you
before you started with buckle up and
prepare for the journey success on
YouTube takes hard work and patience
what has been your experience with that
oh that is so true I will say this is
the hardest job I have ever had the
amount of work involved in making videos
is is challenging you know I I agree
with Dr Andrea thank God for VRA thank
God for your book Sean I mean because
without them it I I wouldn't have known
what to do it would have been so
overwhelming I would have gotten very
discouraged very quickly but following
your plan and
just saying okay the this is going to be
a lot of work this and especially
someone like myself I had no experience
with and with doing any of this I'm in
my 60s you know and I
just took one day at a time and there
were times that I could so relate to
what Dr Andrea is saying you make a
video you work so hard at it you do such
a good job then nobody's watching it or
yes people unsubscribe and you're like
oh my gosh but you have to just
have a tough skin you gotta buckle up as
I said for the journey and persevere and
be consistent and just keep following
the formula that that you you provide
Sean in video ranking Academy follow the
formula just and stick get some type of
schedule for yourself and say every week
I'm gonna put a video out I'm in my case
you know every Saturday morning I'm
going to make sure I have a video to put
out I'm gonna do the best I can with it
and I'm gonna tell myself if nobody
watches it fine if I get unsubscribers
fine I'm just going to be patient I'm
just going to persevere because
something that I really believe and I
think this is so important for people to
understand is that
there are people coming on to YouTube
Every Day hundreds of thousands of
people and they're looking for someone
to connect with
and they may not have found that person
yet and you may be that person and then
eventually just like Dr Andrea said one
day you're looking at your analytics and
you have a video that gets this hockey
stick effect
and it it is it's encouraging and it
helps you persevere but you've got to
stick with it even during the down times
even during the difficult times you just
have to say to yourself This is the best
platform there is yes there's other
social media but you know also as Dr
Andrea said it's very difficult really
to grow on those other platforms but if
you're patient and if you stick with the
program and if you're consistent and you
just tell yourself
okay not every video is going to be
perfect not every video is going to be
successful but it may down the line
someone may find you and then say as Dr
Andrea says she gets emails or comments
from all over the world people saying oh
I really like you oh I really appreciate
this I'll get comments where people will
say oh I've been looking for someone who
could teach me this and teach me the way
you teach it you know and talking about
Dr Andrea when I I'm a fan of her when I
found her I was like oh my gosh I have
arthritis of my hip I'm doing your
exercise stuff I told you earlier you
know and so you just have to be patient
and you have to persevere keep your
spirits up just keep plugging away it's
something you know that we enjoy doing
we have something we want to share and
that's basically it yeah basically trust
the process yes
trust the process that it's going to
work and um if you give up early then a
lot of people give up early and those
are the competitors of my channel that
I'll say okay you want to give up I am
keeping and I'll keep going and that's
the Deep right where a lot of people
leave and they don't come back
and I said no I am going to persevere I
trust the process and um let's go push
keep pushing record press record because
uh you gotta Express record man that
those words are in my mind all the time
you just have to get press records
I I'm I am fired up like I'm literally
like buzzing with energy just you're
you're you're really encouraging my uh
spirit as well just to hear
um the bombs already dropping about the
reality too about the hard work that
goes into this and I can't wait to get
to number three
um but a couple things one if you're
getting value hit the like button we're
talking about 13 things we wish we knew
back when we started on YouTube the
first one was YouTube has advantages
over social other social media platforms
that they don't have
also success on YouTube number two takes
hard work and patience and we're going
to get to the rest in just a second but
um we are also streaming this we're
streaming this on our think media
podcast Channel and in our challenge
Community if you haven't heard we're
doing the tube 1K Challenge and I want
to make sure that if you still want to
get in there's limited replays for it
it's entirely free and so you can
register at learn
video2023.com and we'll put a link in
the description down below as well to be
a part of the free challenge and
um also if uh you're in the challenge
group we are doing a giveaway during
this session and some extra we'll do a
couple questions at the end and whatnot
just in the challenge group and so if
you happen to be watching this publicly
then get registered and get inside
because we'll be cutting the stream
after the 13 points and then um going
into that next section and so I want to
get into number three though and Mary
you hit this one with some very deep
detailed wisdom and it was this be
prepared for negative comments one of
our greatest fears I think all of us is
just the fear of other people's opinions
in general the fear if we're going to
get backlash and I would love for you to
share some wisdom on that what's been
your experience with 849
000 subscribers I could imagine you've
maybe had a hurtful comment or two on
some of your videos just by the sheer
size of the influence of channels that
you've reached I mean you have 45
million views on your channel just a lot
of people in a lot of different moods at
a lot of different times of their day
and so what have you learned about being
prepared for negative comments
you know in the very beginning uh I I
couldn't believe it I I I was shocked I
I was I think I was crying you know and
this is the very beginning
and then after that and yeah I think
maybe my husband is like what what's
what's wrong why are you crying you know
and I said oh someone left me such a
mean comment and he says well what did
they say and I would tell him the
comment and he has a very good sense of
humor and so he would like have a little
I don't know what they call it like a
little back talk type thing I would
never publish it I would usually in the
beginning I would actually re I would
comment back to the person I'd say oh
I'm so sorry that what I said you didn't
like or you know giving this big
explanation and then I would just send
it and then I would say a prayer for
them and I would just try to get it out
of my mind but you have to be prepared
for that but if you can over time just
think well God bless them you know maybe
they're unhappy people they're you know
there are people who say mean things in
life and so I always find just saying a
little prayer for them and just delete
the comment and move on but if you have
anybody in your family or your friends
who has a good sense of humor you should
share the comments with them because
I'll give you an example uh one time a
man left a comment that said
why did this Weeble wobble come up on my
home page I want to like see a real
person who can make bone broth and I
told my husband the comment and we will
get a big of an older lady I'm a little
chubby you know and my husband said oh
just tell them Weebles wobble but they
don't fall down
you know and then another time somebody
said oh my gosh that woman needs to put
down the fork and stop eating and my
husband said to ask them are you going
to finish that yeah
and just silly little quirks and then I
just started laughing about it
but it in in the beginning I will
confess now I don't even notice it and I
I'll you know just delete it and like I
said just say a little prayer for them
obviously it's an unhappy person but uh
when your channel gets bigger
you can't always see every single
comment
um and every once in a while I'll come
across one where someone left something
mean and I wasn't able to delete it and
this is something that you can look
forward to you know for those of you who
are are new to all of this as your
channel grows your viewers who love you
will defend you
and we'll tell the person they need to
leave
which is kind of you know it it that
gives you a nice feeling but yes in the
beginning you just have to you you got
to start
I would say if you're gonna be on
YouTube if you're gonna make videos
you need to start getting a little bit
of a thick skin
you need to say I'm here because I want
to provide something helpful to people
and I know that
there are going to be people who may say
unkind things but I'm going to move past
that because I have a service and I have
interesting information to share and I I
never want a handful of people to keep
me from sharing that information and
making it available to help other people
make their lives better
and there's many more people who
appreciate you make helping them teach
them something to make their life better
and who count on you to show up whatever
your schedule is every week a couple of
times a week once a month whatever the
case may be is they're counting on you
and they're they're looking for you to
be consistent and persevere and push the
negative comments aside
that's some powerful advice and I'm
curious for Dr Andrea have you
experienced any negative comments and
whatever
you're joking no oh my god of course uh
in my case I have to approve every
single comment that is posted on my
channel and I do that so I have to read
every single one I can't answer them
anymore all of them but I do this
because people really sometimes they
disclose medical information
uh their symptoms and then they say
please Dr Forlan contact me here is my
cell phone my address or my email so I
can't allow allow comments just to go
freely on my channel so when I read
comments if they are negative cons I
approve them I do approve I don't delete
uh I approve and sometimes if they are
if they disagree with my medical opinion
I answer them as long as they are polite
and as long as they are you know not
disgraceful or something that using
pressure no not bad language but
sometimes they comment on my accent they
comment on my appearance they comment
saying that she doesn't know anything
about this topic I approve those
comments and sometimes I just ignore
them I don't even I I only answer the
ones that I think my response will be
to this mystify some things that they
were saying like if they say you said
something wrong about the interprematory
diet and especially the canola oil a lot
of people disagree with what I said
about canola oil so I go and I respond
uh if people have if they use some bad
language
then I don't approve if they say
anything bad and they do
um and then I don't approve and I block
that person from posting any other
comment on my channel ever so I have
some rules and but most of the time I
just ignore them in the beginning I was
crying like Mary
but now I think I just might think my
thing must be this thick and I just
ignore and it's okay another comment
about my hair my accent my voice my the
colors that I use whatever it's okay
fine I tell you what this is all too
real and number three is be prepared for
negative comments
um you know some practical tools that
YouTube gives you is there's the a
filter where you can filter certain
words because sometimes maybe people
talk about your teeth or your hair or
something you can actually just trigger
words so they at least go to be having
to be approved I love that Dr Andrea
said she's pre-approving them and then
Mary's learned that over time you kind
of just get used to it and we all have
found that if we imagine a world where
we never stop stepped out and never
faced backlash never face criticism
never faced it's not that we maybe we
would have avoided the pain of one or
two negative comments but we also would
have avoided the impact and purpose of
impacting thousands of people and so
negative comments kind of come with the
territory there are some tools you don't
have to turn comments on we do recommend
doing that because of the community
thing and uh such great advice there I
got a comment recently where someone
said said you are the oldest looking
young person I've ever met and I was
like thanks you know I appreciate that
it's maybe a little bit of gray in the
beard I'm like you know what is he a
child or is he a wise wizard you know we
don't know
um but we got to get into number four
we're gonna do a quick one on this one
um because Mary you submitted this you
said that audio is more important than
video basically talk about like you talk
not worrying too much about the camera
but that audio is a big deal break that
down
oh that is so true I I don't really
think it matters when it comes to
filming today the the tell if the cell
phone is amazing any camera is amazing
you know and the picture is gonna be
fine but if your audio is not good
everybody's gonna notice everybody's
gonna click out of your video you you
have to make sure that your audio is
good and and some of my earlier videos
you know there's like crackling and then
sometimes we would film and then we
would have no sound oh my gosh so
frustrating and the the thing is
you and I'm almost a little embarrassed
to say this is but maybe there are some
people who can relate to this
you have to make sure that your audio is
good because you have to know how to use
your mic you know my husband and I had
as I shared with you you know it's just
my husband and I who who do this and we
had to learn I don't care how old or
young you are you have to learn how to
use your mic you have to make sure that
you have all the right settings and if
you have even if you have a cell phone
you have to make sure that because
sometimes depending on where you're
filming it can get very echoey if you
don't have like a special little mic
attachment you know for your cell phone
uh and that I I realized in the
beginning we were so frustrated because
we couldn't figure out how to properly
use the microphone and the sad thing
about it is do you know all it took to
call the manufacturer's 1-800 number and
they explained it to us and today I'm
sure there's plenty of videos on YouTube
that'll cover pretty much any microphone
you have so many Fantastic videos that
explain in detail how to use different
mics and how to familiarize yourself
with them and the quality of mics today
I think is fantastic but you know how to
use it and you will save a lot of time
because you're going to get you know
you're already dealing with uh you know
sometimes it's a heavy work schedule you
know making your video and maybe you
have family maybe you have young
children
you know there's so many things you know
we have a hundred pound lab he has to go
to Doggy Daycare when we film you know
otherwise there would be no filming so
you have to make sure that you maximize
that time that you set aside to film and
so
spending hours like trying to figure out
the mic and then having problems with it
and then filming oh my gosh it can be so
frustrating so that's just know how to
use your microphone good sound makes all
the difference in the world if your
lighting's not perfect nobody's going to
notice if they can hear you because a
lot of people will just be listening to
you
yeah it's so powerful and I think we can
just put yourself in the seat of the
viewer because as viewers maybe we're
not judging the video quality too bad
but if it's hard to hear the person or
if it's crackly or it's even hurts our
ears you can really lose audience
retention with bad audio and so that was
number four which really leads into
number five and that is you'll get more
views when you put the viewer first one
of the things
yeah one of the things we share here at
think media is it's really not uh you
can make selfish content or you can make
service content and not that anyone is
selfish on YouTube but sometimes if a
channel is all about you well then
what's in it for the viewer and so I
want to start with Dr Andrea and then go
to marry you had some powerful thoughts
on this it's about like putting the
viewer first I mean what is the mission
of your channel it's really the viewer
that you're serving that's at the center
of it break it down yeah uh that's so
true so when I am recording the video
I look at the camera and I always try to
imagine one of my patients behind the
camera that helps a lot because I'm
talking to that person uh and and then I
I just talked to them the same way that
I would talk in my clinic so it's not
about me I never say anything about me
and what's happening to me it's all
about their symptoms raise your pain and
I want them I want them to understand so
I am a teacher by heart I am a professor
of medicine at the University of Toronto
so I teach
other doctors I teach medical students I
teach residents
so when when I teach
I am thinking are they understanding
what I'm saying but when I'm teaching in
person I'm looking at their eyes and
there is this eye contact so I can I I
notice if they are you know paying
attention or not but it's hard when
you're talking to a camera you don't
know if the person is paying attention
or not but I always try to imagine
a patient a person who is going to
listen to this are they understanding am
I clear or not what I say because in
medicine you can use a lot of medical
terms and difficult words like a
cervical radiculopathy that I was
telling you before
and um
so then when I say those long words like
Central sensitization is a big problem
that we have in chronic pain
fibromyalgia then I I know I'm going to
write my editors is going to write on
you know behind me or my site that word
and I know I wanted just to make it
clear and I think that's that connects
with the person right it connects with
the viewer that they they feel that I'm
talking to them I I read his scripts I
most of the videos that I'm not the
exercise exercise videos it's
spontaneous but the ones that I'm
teaching a lecture I read scripts I
write the script and then I read it but
I try not to read too much I try to look
at the camera because I know they're
going to see eye on eye right so the
viewers if you think about the viewer
first um
you're going to be successful don't try
to promote yourself don't worry about
your appearance although I do a little
bit of touch-ups I do a little bit of
makeup I go to the hairdresser before I
record because now
I I started doing this last year Sean
because uh to make me more efficient I
go to the hairdresser Saturday morning
and then Saturday afternoon I record six
seven eight nine videos with the same
hair I just changed my wardrobe but um
uh I do worry a little bit about my
appearance how I look like because I
like to see myself uh you know has a
professional doctor there but that's how
much I worry about myself everything
else but I say the message is thinking
about those patients who will be in pain
and trying to understand what I'm saying
you drop some nuggets there too because
no I think that's incredibly practical I
think a lot of people are encouraged by
hearing oh okay so you kind of have
eventually a Cadence of of when you're
getting your hair done batching eight to
nine videos in one day for busy people
it shows you how it's possible to stay
consistent on YouTube and I even think
actually caring about your appearance is
a service to the viewer just being
thoughtful about on camera though about
the audio thoughtful about the visual
and it's building out your own brand but
of course the viewer is front and center
and Mary you really talked about this
and it just struck me because this is
something that I think comes natural to
you because you're such a person of love
and service but at the same time you
said I knew from the start the channel
was never going to be about me
wow I think a lot of us when we start on
YouTube we think about it as R2 it's
your too you know what I mean we think
oh yeah it's all about me it's the me
show and I get it you know there's room
for of course energy retainers and and
people that might have that kind of
brand but especially here at think media
and video ranking Academy we've also
just discovered that the most practical
Pathway to success is also making it
about the viewer and I'm just inspired
by that phrase break that down a little
bit about you know putting the viewer
first and what that means to you
oh yes I I think that's so important
because after you you might have the
vision of what you're going to make your
videos about especially when you're in
the how to uh business so to speak like
me and Dr Andrea where we're teaching
something
but once you get those first few videos
up you need to really pay attention to
the comments and you really need if you
have a website like I do you really need
to pay attention to the emails and you
need to see what your viewers are asking
you for what they're struggling with and
just like Dr Andrea was saying you know
the people will tell her I have this
pain or that pain I would get it's you
know similar thing is that their pain
points so to speak was you know
struggling with sourdough or or the bone
broth you know not being rich in
gelatinous and what were they doing
wrong and I realized that I really had
to stay on the on that mission so to
speak of always putting what the viewer
wanted always answering the viewers
needs and questions and never making it
about what I wanted to do I might have
said to myself oh gee I was planning on
doing X but the that may not be what the
viewer is interested in and as you make
more and more videos it really helps you
fine-tune what your viewer wants to
learn from you why did they come to you
in the first place and maybe watch one
video and then maybe watch another one
and then maybe subscribe and if all of a
sudden you start making the channel more
about yourself and talking a lot about
yourself
you're going to lose them and they're
going to be upset with you and I I
learned that early on you know this is
definitely about things that you you you
wish you knew or whatever uh
I would talk to other creators you know
that's the thing about YouTube even
though there's a lot of people on
YouTube YouTube is actually I feel it's
like a small community and you get to
know a lot of people in your Niche and
it goes back to what we were talking
about before you know you've got it's
hard work you got to be persistent you
got to stick with it but it's very
doable and you can have success but you
always need to be putting the viewer
first and thinking about what the viewer
wants from you because I would talk to
other creators and they would say oh you
know I'm getting a little tired they X
and touch they always want to see this
video or that and I just really want to
do this and maybe I want to Vlog and
whatever and I would say no you know you
you you have to give the viewer they
came to you in the first place for a
reason and I think if you don't yes you
have to follow Trends in your Niche and
definitely respond uh maybe to things
that are under your umbrella so to speak
but maybe not specific to exactly what
you started with because everybody grows
when they're on YouTube and broadens a
little but again all of that growth all
of that broadening is because it's how
your viewers are directing you
you just dropped some major bombs and I
encourage everybody to re-watch that
entire part there because it's also true
I mean you joined our program video
ranking Academy back in I think we were
saying 2016 and then you started posting
in 2017 and you started posting in 2018
yes and and
it's easy then you go 2019 2020 2021
2022 four years it's easy to get almost
bored sometimes too or you just kind of
want to get distracted and you're like
exactly like other creators will say I
just kind of want to go do my own thing
which is yeah you got to express
yourself and you gotta you know evolve
and you want to make sure there's still
joy in it but your commitment to keeping
the viewer Central I think speaks to why
you're about to hit a million
subscribers I mean you literally are
going to get a gold play button and that
really also ties us into tip number six
here which is the more focused your
channel is the faster it will grow this
is hard for people because when people
are like oh do I need to Niche down do I
need a niche but the thing I would say
is that's why we kind of reframe this
point okay Niche is important we have a
course called Niche Finder but I think a
word I like even better in 2023 is focus
like what's the focus of your channel
it's hard to follow someone that is
distracted it's hard to follow somebody
if you don't know where they're going so
what's the focus of your channel and so
Dr Andrea you mentioned this one as well
and uh you have a clear Niche what have
you noticed in terms of how that's
helped your channel grow
absolutely because
um
some people ask me they write comments
or my colleagues they ask me oh can you
do on this or that like I just got a
comment this week can I can I can you do
a video on teeny tools
and I I always respond saying I already
have a can't respond that I says I say
sorry that's outside of the scope of
this channel this channel is about
chronic pain I only do videos about
chronic pain because it's easy for me to
talk about many other topics of Medicine
uh and uh then I could be deviating but
I have to focus and I have a list of
topics that I want to talk and I make a
list and is it does it fit with my scope
which is also things that I feel
comfortable I cannot talk about
everything in chronic pain so I don't
talk about interventions and I don't
feel that I'm an expert and I don't
pretend that I'm expert and when I do
that I ask some experts to review my
scripts and to check for me if the
evidence is proper or not but if I want
to touch everything about pain like
acute pain acute pain is different from
chronic pain I'm not expert in acute
pain I don't work in emergency
department and treat people who come
with acute pain so I'm not going to talk
about that I talk to people that develop
chronic pain chronic pain is a different
disease so you need to focus in narrow
and I think your audience can relate to
that because then they that's what they
signed up they subscribe to my channel
because I talk about chronic pain so
that's what they're going to find my
channel
that's amazing and we are going through
13 things we wish we knew back when we
were starting our channels both of
course Mary and Dr Andrea and think
media we all start at zero
um and there's things we maybe would
have done differently but it's helpful
to have a guide on the way and
specifically as it relates to Niche I
want to remind you that there is a
limited time offer happening right now
on a bundle of training where it's not
just our signature course video ranking
Academy but included in it is our
program called YouTube Niche Finder if
you want to find your focus and narrow
things down
learnvideo2023.com is where this limited
offer is we're doing a 1K tube 1K
challenge right now and uh if you
haven't registered for that there's
still a couple more days of that free
challenge but whenever we do these it's
when our best offer of the year is in
terms of our online course and our
community as well as some really cool
exclusive bonuses including our brand
new shorts Master Class YouTube towards
master class that's being recorded in
February and you'll get a ticket so all
of that is that learn video
2023.com but I'm excited we have so much
value already if you've been getting
value I'd love to hear your aha moment
in the comments or and uh hit the like
button we've already gotten through
multiple tips and we're jumping into
number seven which is this is a growing
industry and therefore it leads to many
opportunities and this was really uh
inspired by you Dr Andrea you said
there's really a whole industry
gravitating around YouTube and so break
down what you mean by that and some of
the ways your world view has expanded
after starting your channel oh my God
yes I could um yeah talk a lot about
about a lot of things one thing that I
never imagined was I did this as a hobby
for myself and to help my patients but I
never imagined that uh that would be
opportunities for example simple to
write a book or opportunities to be
promoted at the University I am being
promoted and writing my dual CNL for
promotion to full professor at the
University of Toronto because of YouTube
I get a lot of students and I got awards
for mentoring Awards because of YouTube
I got an award from the Alberta pain
Society because of the so Awards and
recognition and promotion but also the
industry around me I get so many
requests that people want to me to
review products I don't do product
review it's I I still don't do it for
some other reasons but I'm
every day they want to send me products
and I like pillows and a treadmill and
massage guns for me to use and review I
have an affiliate marketing with Amazon
and there are a lot of products that
people buy there and I get commission
even you know not related to the things
that I mentioned in my products but um
you know the 24 hours after they connect
trauma Zone and they buy anything I get
commission so I get a lot of I use my
gift cards from Amazon and I have bought
a lot of books to read
so and not only this but there is also
opportunity to collaborate with other
people I did some videos with other
YouTubers in the area of medicine
Pharmacy people that I would never even
know that they existed and we could do
things together so I think this is great
because uh it opened up uh some plan for
me in the future like uh if one day I
can't practice medicine anymore I want
to retire from medicine I know what I'm
going to do for the rest of my life
it's going to be creating content
educating people online courses that's
another thing I like to start this year
online courses because people are asking
me if I have online courses so I think I
need to start that
man it's so inspiring and you know I
feel very privileged because we were
able to connect off camera before and
it's been in a bizarre turn of events as
you both have been putting in a lot of
hard work growing your channels you both
have had a similar opportunity because
of YouTube you both have gotten book
deals and Publishers have reached out I
mean tell us just a brief and I don't
want to go too far off script here but
like you know Mary maybe we'll start
with you I was like when is your
cookbook coming out and I'm just joking
and you go well actually but it turns
out and so tell just tell that quick
story and then I want to hear Dr Andrea
briefly about your book deal as well
yes as I shared with you I was very
surprised that uh someone emailed me and
you know I was thinking to just scam you
know you get these emails and all and my
husband said no it's legitimate this is
coming from random house and I'm like oh
my gosh yeah
and as I said I I was discovered Sean
I'm telling you I have to thank you and
video ranking Academy because if I
didn't have a YouTube channel this would
have never happened
the man saw me making sauerkraut
we answered a specific question you put
out that video this guy from the book
publisher discovers your sauerkraut
video and then that leads to a book deal
and we're gonna have you back on the
podcast uh closer to the book launch but
but it's coming out in August 2023.
August 2023. do you know what it's
called or what it's about I mean I'm
sure I have to surprise you okay you're
surprised I mean we can you know all the
wisdom and everything on your channel
and then Dr Andrea some your book's
coming out sooner and so yeah oh my God
Sean that was something that I never
imagined actually when I opened my
channel in 2019 I had just turned 50
years old and I said oh I should write a
book but I don't know I'm too lazy I
don't want to so I will open a YouTube
channel but then I had so many scripts
because of all the videos that I had
published so I said maybe it's time and
I I listened to one of your podcasts in
the think media podcast that you said
you have to write a book to determine
you know to establish yourself as an
authority I said oh my God okay Sean is
talking to me so I called a publisher no
agent no nothing I waited until I had a
100 000 subscribers that I got that uh
the plate
and then I I chose one publisher and I
said listen I I like to write a book for
people with chronic pain and he said who
are you and so when I told him that I
had a Channel with 100 000 subscribers
he said ah okay let's talk about it so
then he assigned me an editor so my book
is coming this April is for people with
chronic pain it has QR codes to a lot of
my videos and I'm super excited I think
the book is going to help a lot of
people with chronic pain around the
world
I'm congratulations to both of you and
you know it's such a powerful
illustration we could spend a 25 part
series on the podcast about how this
industry is growing and how it can lead
to so many different opportunities it
literally the publishing industry is
flipped you did the right move first you
built the platform first the audience
first and I think what did what was the
quote whose quote was that before we got
on camera that what what the publisher
said was no it's like we
yeah the editor said to me oh yeah we
just go on YouTube now and and look for
people that we want to have right books
for us so we go to the publisher at
random house says we go to YouTube to
look for people to write books for us
friends YouTube is is the place to plant
your flag and the world is taking note
um and so I love that this is a growing
industry but this gets into tip number
eight we're going through 13 tips don't
fall into the comparison trap and uh
don't worry if you think your videos
aren't as great as other creators just
do your best I think Mary this was you
tell me a little bit about this and you
know uh you started with that don't
worry if your videos aren't as great as
others we're all starting at different
places what has kind of been your
journey with uh this tip
yeah I think it's very easy especially
especially starting out
still new to
to you know kind of finding your comfort
zone in terms of how you're going to
make your videos how you're going to
present yourself how you're going to
start your video all of that and you
make your video and you do the best that
you can but your chances are you're
watching other videos on YouTube as well
maybe in your Niche maybe in other areas
that have interest to you and you look
at these other videos and you're like
wow those people are really good my
video doesn't look as good you know and
it's easy to start making that
comparison and then you can become
discouraged and that's where you have to
stop comparing yourself to other people
because going back to what we said
earlier you have to be persistent you
have to keep your spirits up and you
just have to forge ahead and compare I
really learned and I think this was
something that you know I learned either
in the from people talking in the
Facebook group and from things that you
and your team have said compare yourself
to yourself
make your next video compare your next
or or make your next video a little
better just like one bit better I forget
exactly your exact term but just do make
it a little better just do a little
better each time and compare yourself to
yourself and compete with yourself just
making yourself a little better every
few steps of the way and you will do so
much for your mental state for your
psyche watch videos enjoy them when you
stop comparing yourself to other people
you do better and you enjoy watching
other videos more because you're looking
at them to learn or to know whatever you
want to know you're not comparing
yourself get out of that mindset say I'm
just going to compare myself to the last
video I made how can I be better
powerful wisdom I mean I've heard it
said that comparison is the killer of
creativity and the thief of joy and uh
number nine is find a posting schedule
that works for you I want to hear from
you in just a second Mary and Dr Andrea
you already shared some cool tips about
batching but I'd love for you to also
speak to you to kind of upped your game
recently in terms of uploads by tapping
into YouTube shorts so what is uh your
kind of posting schedule and some tips
you've learned okay so this uh changed a
lot over time in the beginning 2019 I
was able to post only one video a month
that's
that was I what I could do because I was
doing everything learning everything and
that was fine I was happy with that and
I kept posting one video a month until
end of 2020. and I was very successful
already by January 2021 I had 20 000
subscribers still posting one video a
month
and I was still not even monetizing
because I had no idea that you could
monetize when you had a thousand
subscribers but anyways
um then in 2021 I said okay I think now
I learned the the craft and I'm going to
start posting once a week that's when I
started
and one long video once a week and only
and I was possible because I hired my
son to edit my videos and now this
January 2023 I said I'm going to post
every day so one long video once a week
and one short every day and so far it's
been working it's a little bit more work
to my schedule but um I will try to do
that because I think the art of shorts
is really fun and I like it
and um I learned also from uh your think
medium that batch record is the way to
do and I I'm so happy that I learned
that because I in one Saturday last
Saturday recorded six videos but I my
record was nine videos in one Saturday
so then I'm free for nine weeks and last
weekend I recorded six long videos and
53 shorts
that's you are a machine and uh you know
it's cool to see the the the results too
here I mean this is looking using vid IQ
at Dr Andrea stats 1.3 million views in
the last 28 days 14 000 new subscribers
with the channel getting a lot of
momentum but I think part of that too is
30 uploads and the secret to those more
uploads are YouTube shorts and we always
say that like if you want if you double
your uploads you can double your views
because you are also giving yourself
more at bats you've got fourteen
thousand twelve thousand thirty four
thousand on videos that are of course
arguably easier to produce you're
limited to 60 seconds you're limited to
vertical and so it's so inspiring to see
and definitely we'll link to both
channels in the show notes so that you
can even kind of look at some of the
lessons there but uh Mary I would love
to hear about your publishing schedule
you you articulated this you said you
know know find something that works for
you I'm inspired that Dr Andrew also
said that I only posted one a month
early on because people are asking
especially in the challenge like what is
the perfect number well the perfect
number is what you're actually able to
do because it doesn't really matter if
you can't post one every week that's
okay post one a month but if you can
increase your schedule especially as you
develop the skills and the momentum like
then do that as well and so how about
for you you know what what have you
learned about not worrying about what
everybody else is doing in this area
yes I think it's very important the only
way at least for me and I think probably
other people can relate to this is if
you're going to be consistent
you have to find a schedule that works
for you if someone posts every day or
three times a week or whatever the case
may be and you see no way of being able
to do that then don't worry about it
post what works for you and I put out
one video on Saturday morning
and then I I've started doing shorts I
have a lot to learn
and I just so far I Dr Andrew is an
inspiration to me because so far I'm
just putting one out on Wednesday
and so uh I and I release you know I try
to release things at the same time I'm
usually I'm in the central time zones I
try to do 10 o'clock sad Saturday
morning for my long form content and
then uh Wednesday you know somewhere in
that 10 o'clock range for my short and
that's really all I can do my some of my
videos my you know the regular videos
not the shorts are so long and so
detailed that sometimes if I tried to uh
put out two a week it would be very hard
for me and I recognize that and I I want
to be able to also you know live a life
I don't want to be under a lot of stress
where uh I'm over tired or whatever the
case may be because all of that shows
through in videos if you are finding
that you know you're tired or you're not
enjoying doing it anymore you may not be
consistent you may not persevere and so
it's that's why it's very important to
find a schedule that works for you and
like Dr Andrea I tried a batch film also
and I will know in advance I usually put
together an editorial calendar for the
whole year
uh with the four videos and maybe a few
extra ideas
um and then I also leave myself a little
wiggle room uh if there's a particular
Trend in my Niche that that my viewers
want me to address but I pretty much
know for the most part everything I'm
gonna film for one year and so I will
film my four videos a month at if I can
I'll try to do it in one day and if not
then I'll just set aside two days and
I'll just do two and two if if I have
exceptionally long detailed videos and I
give myself a little wiggle room and I
don't stress uh if I can't exactly stick
with that schedule and I also build in
breaks especially around the holidays so
that I'm not uh you know like I'm not
going to make my husband work on
Father's Day weekend saying you gotta
help me edit this video know you know
and so I will build in breaks around
holidays and that really helps and that
way I'm I'm not overtired I'm not
stressed and I can manage it but
whatever you decide
stick with it and be consistent because
your viewers are going to start to
expect that video to come out at that
particular time whatever time you pick
if it's once a month at a certain time
stick with it and eventually over time
if you can add in extra videos all the
better and if you can add in shorts all
the better like you said The more you do
the more views yes you are going to get
and so but do it in stages just be
consistent and do what you can what's
you can handle
I'm very inspired Mary because both you
and Dr Andrea I know we all share this
similar ethic for family for health
naturally both of you you care about
healthy living and natural food and Dr
Andrea is helping us be healthy and
overcome pain
but what's inspiring is also one of the
reasons we all love YouTube is because
it can support your lifestyle because it
can work for you when you're not working
so you've just developed an asset as
well and it's like when I look at your
metrics and how you followed the video
ranking Academy system you probably of
course realized that with your study
four uploads a month in the last 28 days
you grew 24 000 subscribers and 1.6
million views and that wasn't because of
the four uploads it was because the
library of content that you've built and
so it's just so inspiring because when
you're on a break you've got videos
working for you that are five years old
when you don't you want to recover and
rest you've got videos working for you
and it was inspiring because you know Dr
Andrea has hired her son and so other
people hire editors but you at your
YouTube Partner manager that reached out
to you actually said so tell me about
your team and you were like team
just speak to my husband like that's it
and and you're on your way to a million
subscribers a gold play button and it
just proves that that having a system
having a rhythm pacing yourself as well
this wasn't overnight for any of us this
has been building for years but when you
feel the emotions of hitting that gold
play button that's going to be
absolutely incredible we're going
through 13 tips and I appreciate you
being here for the power around I mean
you know I tried to consolidate it down
to 10 but you you guys wrote Such
incredible stuff we had to take it to
13. so number 10 is learn how YouTube
works and get help and Dr Andrea I love
what you said you said I learned a new
science called youtubeology yeah I've
never heard that before but I I know
exactly what you mean but break that
down about you know your journey of
studying learning investing in yourself
in terms of getting to where you're at
to almost 500 000 subscribers on YouTube
today
yeah you have to be a self uh learner
because there's so much to learn
not just about the algorithm but uh
learning about how to post you know what
do you choose I put closed captions in
all of my videos and I put now in 53
different languages because people ask
me so I'm always learning how do I put
closed captions in these languages
and how do I turn on this button and uh
what is important what is not so
it's a new science it's a new way of you
know it's a platform that you if you
don't Master it the analytics is another
thing that is overwhelming a lot of data
the other tools that you have around
that can help you I really love vidiq
because it helps me so much but I did
not know it existed until it came to
your course so there are a lot of things
you need to be ready to be a student of
YouTube and spend time not just doing
videos but learning about YouTube I read
what the CEO of YouTube she writes um I
I I listen to the YouTube Creator uh
every week they post they have a YouTube
channel and every week they post what is
new what's changing on YouTube all of
those things so
it's investing your time in learning a
new skill
and as you were specifically learning
the video record Academy system the 7rs
what I mean was it was overwhelming a
lot to learn was it easy to follow and
and what is your relationship with now
having a system today yeah I I when I
joined uh VRA I did the 1K challenge in
May 2021 and I joined VRA in June I kind
of devoured the materials I did
everything I have my binder there with
notes and everything
uh it was just God sent because it
opened my mind and said oh this it's
this it's a everything organized like
everything that I tried to learn myself
and you put in a way that makes sense
and your book also very helpful so I'm
really thankful that I came across the
VRA Academy I'm I'm big I I sent people
to the VRA all the time as you probably
know and
um I I think you need that it's like
school you know people a lot of my
colleagues ask me where did you learn
YouTube I'd like to open a YouTube
channel I said there is a school for
that there is a YouTube school you have
and then I tell them about the VRA
it's amazing and uh thank you for your
kind words so glad you've been getting
value
um you know Mary one of the things you
wrote in regards to this was also I know
there's different methodologies for for
YouTube there's different ways to
approach it there's lots of different
paths to success but you said that when
you first joined video record Academy
you had some of your personal opinions
even some ego and it was a little bit
different than how you thought you were
going to approach YouTube so what was
your experience with that and then the
result after implementing what you
learned
well yes I think that's very true you
know you kind of have with the I think
for a lot of people when you're thinking
of doing a YouTube channel you have a
plan in your mind now mind you I knew
nothing about making a YouTube channel
but you know I think sometimes we all
have a little bit of ego and we're like
oh well okay I may not know how to do a
YouTube channel but I know a few things
about cooking and I'm gonna do it this
way and I'm gonna have this title or
this thumbnail or whatever the case may
be just from you know
again not comparing because you have you
don't have a channel yet but you're just
looking at what other people are doing
and so you think you uh know what what
how you how you you're going to learn
how to do a YouTube channel but you and
your mind know how you're gonna design
it or whatever and
then when I took your course and I also
like Dr Andrea I've read both your uh
first and uh the uh revised uh book that
you have the revised edition the second
edition and I had to laugh at myself you
know I remember the very first day
watching the first video in video
ranking Academy and I was very humbled
and I was like whoa I have a lot to
learn I need to put my ego on the back
burner I I don't know the right way to
do this I don't know the right way to do
a title I don't know the right way to
make a thumbnail I don't even know the
right way how to make a video you know
all the things that you teach in video
ragging Academy with your formula uh is
very important and you have to follow it
this is I get sometimes a little
frustrated with people because they'll
say oh tell me how did you build your
channel whatever the case may be and
I'll say I took Sean connell's video
ranking Academy and but I I'm going to
tell you that when you take his video
ranking Academy do what he tells you to
do put your ego on the back Runner stop
thinking you have the right answer stop
thinking you know what to do because you
know nothing
[Laughter]
Sean has proved time and time again that
he knows how to teach this and you have
to do what he has to do and I've known
people who are like oh well you know I
want to do it this way or that way I
said no do what he tells you to do
follow his program follow the plan
you have the best you have the best I
think in my humble opinion this is the
best plan out there because you you're
very simple you make it very clear so
whether you have experience or no
experience with filming none of it
matters you start right at the beginning
you make it very clear for people but
they have to follow you they have to do
what you tell them to do so if you can
just assume that you really don't know
what what you should do and you're going
to follow your Mentor Sean and his team
you're going to have success I think Dr
Andrea and I prove that you know we both
followed his plan and and be a learner
as Sean says be a lifelong learner yeah
and just
follow the plan
man I appreciate your kind words and and
I think you know what's humbling to hear
you say all that but but it really is a
system and I mean that's that has been
my dream and my mission was to break it
into a system so that it could be
repeatable and that there could be
predictable success not just one person
gets lucky or because of a particular
thing so thank you for sharing that and
it goes beyond of course video ranking
Academy I mean that is our system is
that is our course and we do have that
special on it learn video 2023 but as Dr
Andrew mentioned as well like there's
continuous learning so we hope you are a
part of our community and others I mean
it's like we're voracious Learners here
and I know both of you are as well
reading podcasts because it's a changing
industry and uh the only way to win is
to learn faster than anyone else I heard
that quote before there's so many it's
overwhelming in kind of today's world
there's new tools there's AI tools but
all of it is also helping us go faster
if we keep learn learning and so I
appreciate your kind words well we're
going to land the plane we got the final
three tips and we're gonna jump into
number 11 and I'm gonna stick with Mary
on this one just because you had a
unique experience with collaborating
with channels that weren't aligned with
yours and a little bit of advice on
collabs we saw that there was open doors
and collabs can be a good thing but
what's your warning here Mary
I think you need to be very careful when
you do collaborations first of all you
need to know a lot about the other
person and you need to know about their
Channel and you need to know about Their
audience uh it's not helpful or useful
to you to do a collaboration with
someone who doesn't have a similar
audience to you
and I made some mistakes like that in
the beginning and I wish someone had
told me that because to give you an
example someone had said to me oh let's
do a collaboration and the person had a
channel you know larger than me very
nice person and she said let's show what
people got or well let's show what we
got at the thrift shop or something like
that
and so I thought well that's not really
in my Niche but just a nice person okay
you know I'll do it the comments that I
got oh my gosh and I'm sure I lost
subscribers was I don't care what you
bought at the thrift shop can you please
make a sourdough bread you know and it
was it was a copy you know it was a
little bit of a comedy show and I made a
few more mistakes like that and then I
realized
okay if I'm gonna do a collaboration and
then also too you need to make sure that
the people you do collaborations with
are nice people and that they don't say
something uncomplementary to you you
know but uh I think that
you pick people that are in your Niche
that make such a big difference I've
done collaborations with other
traditional food cooks and I think those
have done you know they've gone very
well I I've made sometimes I was
contacted and this is something I want
to say to those of you who are new uh to
if you're just beginning to grow your
YouTube channel never be afraid to reach
out to a larger YouTuber in your niche
I've had people contact me who had maybe
10 000 subscribers and they were like oh
can we can I do a a collaboration with
you and the person and I got to talking
we had so much in common loving the book
nourishing Traditions by Sally found we
just really hit it off and so we did a
collaboration on how to make sourdough
pizza pie and so now so that's just a
little little thing that that I want to
share but be be careful don't don't do
things with people and Dr Andrea touched
on this before about people asking her
to make videos that are not that are
over and above chronic pain
you gotta stay with what your viewers
want and you don't want to get comments
like I don't care what you bought at the
thrift shop
I love this theme too because what
you're hitting on is what you both
mentioned earlier which is focus like
staying focused staying aligned just
getting subscribers it's not necessarily
a good thing because what if they're the
wrong subscribers what if it confuses
the YouTube algorithm and if you want to
write down one of the acronyms we've
been doing in the challenge is focus
stands for follow one course until
successful Focus follow one course and
so oh this is a really famous person
that wants to collab well if they bring
an audience that's not going to engage
with your future content or the brand of
your channel then it actually could be
more harmful than it is helpful so I
love that tip well we're going through
13 tips we're on number 12 and this is
probably the one I'm most excited about
because we've talked a lot about of
course the opportunity on YouTube to
make money the opportunity to get
subscribers growing your influence
growing your income but ultimately
YouTube number 12 can make a real impact
in people's lives and you both touched
on this but I want to start with Dr
Andrea like when you think about what
are some of the stories you've heard or
the difference that you starting a
YouTube channel has made in the lives of
people
uh oh my God there's so many stories
Sean and um I remember one that uh
really made me cry
I made a video about shoulder pain and
uh it's for tendinitis of the shoulder
bursitis it's one of the my longest
videos and it has 7.5 million views
and then I got a comment I got a on
Facebook a person from Africa contacted
me
and he said his wife 40 years old his
wife had had a stroke and she had uh
shoulder pain and he asked me if she
could um use the the same exercises well
I never respond to people giving medical
advice that would be unprofessional so I
can't I said to him sorry I can't say if
anything about your wife's condition but
I said this video is not for that kind
of pain I don't have a video for that so
I cried
when I read that comment and I sent that
response and I said I know how to help
that person
so I was I I opened a comment again and
I said I'm going to make a video just
for your wife so I made another video of
a shoulder pain after stroke because the
exercises were different and then I
replied to him he said here's the Right
video for your wife and then he sent me
a video of her he recorded her with his
camera and sent um a video to my private
uh he messaged me on Facebook and he
said look she's doing your exercise and
then I cried again so you know where in
the world I would imagine that I have an
impact on a woman in Africa who had a
stroke and she can't afford she's a
terrible there's no physiotherapy where
she lives and I'm not a physiotherapist
I'm a doctor but whatever I know I was I
want to share with the world and there's
so many other stories of people who told
me that they can't afford exercises or
even to see a pain specialist like me
and I'm the only resource that they have
it really touches my heart and that's
what gives me energy every day to be
thinking about this work and gives you
personal satisfaction and that's why I'm
here in this earth to help people and if
I know all of this about chronic pain I
want to share with anyone who suffers
from this terrible disease
man that is super inspiring and I'm
curious Mary you know uh you've gotten
emails you've gotten
um comments what's maybe one story of
just discovering the impact that your
content has made
well the the most inspiring and story
that I ever it was in a comment that
someone had left me it was a young woman
and she told me her story that she never
like really knew her mother and didn't
have a a good upbringing and now was in
her early 20s and she was in therapy and
I couldn't believe she was leaving me
all of this and her therapist said
yes you don't have a mother yes you know
she didn't apparently have any good role
models in her life and the therapist
said find someone like on TV or in the
movies that you feel is like a nice
person someone that maybe you want to
emulate to grow up to be like and then
just start to watch that person learn
about them read about them whatever the
case may be and learn from them
and I couldn't believe it I was shocked
when she ends the note and she says
you're that person for me you're the
mother or in her case she was saying
grandmother the grandmother I never had
and I watch your videos and I watch how
kind you speak to people and you don't
you're not a zealot you don't tell
people they have to do everything
perfect you tell them it's okay if
you're not perfect just start with a
roast chicken and go from there you know
don't worry about anything we're not
expected to be perfect we're home cooks
and she said I also read how you write
to people in the comments and I'm
learning your way of speaking and your
way of commenting and how nice you are
to people even when maybe they're not so
nice to you
I I couldn't believe this I mean this
was so beyond teaching somebody how to
make a roast chicken and make chicken
bone broth that
even now when I think about it it really
touches a chord with me and she's always
stayed in touch with me and the fact
that
just having cooking videos could have an
impact on somebody like that
this is why I say there's somebody out
there who's looking for you and somebody
who wants to connect with you
and learn from you and maybe even this
is that that's a very heartfelt and
touching story but I have people who
will say oh I just love watching your
channel I'm not a very good cook but I'm
learning how to speak English from you
you know which is cute but it it's those
stories and her story was the most the
the strongest one that had the strongest
effect on me but I do get a lot of uh
comments like that oh you're the mother
of the grandmother I never had no one
ever taught me how to make these things
never to no one ever taught me you know
how to because I also have videos on
home canning how to can foods and
they're like oh my gosh this is
fantastic I I never knew how to do this
and
the fact that people feel that way that
I I could be a motherly figure or a
grandmother grandmotherly figure to them
it brings me a lot of joy
man I was getting chills as you were
talking and it it does it's inspiring
because it's so true because even if
you're just making cooking videos
you're creating Community you could be
encouraging somebody someone said
earlier they discovered US during the
pandemic and we were helpful to their
mental health because people are in our
homes we are maybe we don't have mentors
or a grandmothers in our life or
different things and so maybe you're
just doing gaming content or you're
doing something practical and you don't
think of it as having this Deep Impact I
want to encourage everybody listening to
this your content can make a real impact
in people's lives and I want you to
imagine like you know I just watched I'm
not sure Dr Andrea and Mary if you've
ever seen It's a Wonderful Life you
probably have it's a classic movie I'm
39 and I hadn't watched it you know
until my wife was like shaming me she's
like wait you haven't seen it and I was
like yeah I've never seen it so is this
Christmas season that I just watched it
and it just proposes a powerful question
of a guy who was experiencing a lot of
challenges and and being very
discouraged and even suicidal
an angel from heaven came and showed him
his life had he never existed and all
the people that would have missed out on
his impact and he would have never
married his wife so they would have
never had kids and maybe that's a little
bit profound and and big Vision to be
talking to this but I think about it you
have almost a million subscribers Mary
you have almost a million subscribers Dr
Andrea 500 000 both growing at this
rapid clip and it's like if you had
never punched fear in the face and press
record those subscribers wouldn't be
there those views wouldn't be there the
shoulder uh challenges that individual
was having discovering your video Dr
Andrea like that she might not have had
that breakthrough somebody that was in
it was yeah it's just bone broth but the
emotional state they were in and I know
it's kind of heavy but I want to mention
a quote you wrote Dr Andrea related to
this you wrote when you were filling out
these tips your content can make a real
impact on people's lives you said with
influence
comes greater responsibility
and I think that sometimes maybe in the
challenge we think about like okay yeah
let's grow and yeah let's make an impact
but I think that sometimes we don't
think about the responsibility of being
a content creator just speak a little
bit to that before we jump into the 13th
Point Dr Andrea I love that she shared
that and so you feel the weight on your
shoulders what is that like
yeah especially because I'm talking to
people who have chronic pain Sean and uh
chronic pain is such a harsh disease
you're you know suffering you're tired
you you don't have time for your family
and um there there's not an ending to
the suffering
and so when I'm putting myself there and
trying to teach them and sometimes I I
have to say hard words to them I I have
to say sometimes chronic pain will not
go away so you have to learn how to
manage your flare-ups
it is
it is hard because I don't know
thousands of people will listen to me
and what they will do with that
information am I helping them I'm really
I really want to help but what if
someone feels the other way all this is
never going to go away I will in my life
so I really need to show compassion
empathy give them hope
I think for me when I'm recording the
videos I try to smile I think smiling to
the camera is so important because these
people need a smile they need hope they
need a so I always try to end with you
know my shoulders relaxed and breathing
and I teach them relaxation because it
is hard and um I don't want to give a
more pessimistic views and and pessimism
to them but I need to tell them the
truth chronic pain is chronic you have
to learn and sometimes will help you to
get better but most of the time you will
have to manage your pain
so that's a heavy weight on my shoulders
but I I read the comments and people say
that it has been helpful most people
complain that they still are in pain
they're trying to do things and they are
not getting better but a lot of people
are feeling better because pain is so
subjective
so that was number 12 your content can
make a real impact in people's lives
bringing us to number 13 and I love this
one prepare for Success 13 things we
wish we knew when we were starting and
this one surprised me because you kind
of submitted your thoughts on this topic
ahead of time and I pulled this one out
and and have a question for you we're
going to start with Dr Andrea
um you've put in a lot of hard work you
have had setbacks challenges any content
creator knows whether the audio was
wrong or challenges in editing or
learning new skills but after all your
hard work I mean you've blown past 100
000 subscribers but when you look at
this picture I'm just curious Dr Andrea
like how does this make you feel when
you reflect over the sacrifice and the
hard work and the impact what are just
some of the emotions that come to mind
when you think about all that you've
achieved on YouTube and getting over
that fear of starting and punching fear
and the face and growing your Channel
yeah so I like to say that for me
success is when my mother
started recommending my videos to all of
her friends because my mother was the
most critical person of me right
in the beginning I didn't even tell her
that I was doing videos because I was
afraid how she was going to look at my
hair and everything but
when I crossed that bridge and she now
starts recommending for me that success
I but I think success is when you know
you get people looking at you and they
look at you different and
um they think that you are making tons
of money and now you became a YouTuber
that's another thing that success brings
with YouTube
and um some people tell me don't say
that you are a YouTuber because YouTuber
has a bad connotation
tell that you're a Creator and I said
well
in the hospital my patients I I do I
really have to think about how they are
thinking about me I have patients that
they say oh my doctor is now a YouTuber
that's a bad thing but others that look
at me and they say oh it's almost like
looking at a celebrity
and it comes with the price because your
image is now your Public Image
and I go to places now like medical
conferences and people look at me say
and they point to me and I don't like
that because I say I'm not famous I'm
just doing my work so you have to be
prepared for people that will see you
has a a YouTuber and what is the image
that that brings and other people that
will admire you and what I you know I've
been proposed many times on YouTube
people who want to marry me and so you
need to be prepared for all of those
uh positives and negatives I'm getting
proposals you know because
yeah I guess you too I guess you also
have those kind of comments and um so
you need to be prepared for the bad side
of success and the good side of success
something that I I never thought that
this would really happen I just when I
opened my channel I said only my
patients will watch this and and I'll be
you know uh nobody will notice me but it
didn't happen a lot of people noticed me
and YouTube started recommending me
through the whole world
and um yeah you need to be prepared
because you never know where this is
going to take you
yes uh such wisdom and Mary I want to
hear from you as we think about this as
well you've had some um uh some
interesting stories you know now you're
getting recognized in public and whatnot
but I am curious I just want to say I
just respect your hustle and your hard
work and it's just amazing to be a part
of your journey book deal all this kind
of stuff but when you look at this
picture and you think about when YouTube
sent you this play button and you opened
it up how did it feel and and how did it
feel related to all of the work and
effort you'd put in up until that point
well I couldn't believe it I I I
couldn't believe I had a hundred
thousand subscribers I felt so happy
that there were a hundred thousand uh
viewers who wanted to join me on this
traditional foods journey in keeping
these traditional food skills alive uh
and being in my age too in my 60s and I
remember when I shared that uh play
button with my viewers I had my husband
and son here and it's it's in terms of
preparing for Success it was so
wonderful to have a son in his twenties
who's like my mother's a YouTuber yeah
and he was very cute because he would
say at his college you know especially
now with the size of the channel That
girls will come up to them and say oh I
love your mother I watch her on YouTube
and he's like Mom you're like the social
media person and I'm not and I'm in my
20s you know
but it's it's very cute you know but
there are oh sorry that's amazing well
tell me the story too you said you know
as your channel grows people are gonna
start to recognize you when you're out
and about has that happened for you oh
yes it it happens quite a bit I I laugh
sometimes people will uh they'll just
stop me and they'll go is your name Mary
and I'm like yes and then they'll say do
you have a YouTube channel Mary's nest
and yes you know and the funny thing
about it is everybody wants to take
selfies with you make sure you leave the
house looking nice because I'm thinking
that there are Selfies out there of me
not looking you know my hair is like
disheveled probably you know and I tend
to not wear makeup talking like with Dr
what Dr Andrea was saying I try to put a
little makeup on before I make my videos
you know but I generally don't wear it
out in public you know and I I'm looking
probably a little more disheveled but uh
no it's cute you know people start they
they know all your little buzzwords as I
was telling you earlier you know with
the bone broth people will just shout
out to me Rich and gelatinous I know you
you know
and uh you know it's sort of the little
tagline that I have bone broth ferment
sourdough and more and it's very cute
you know people are very nice but
it
there are pros and cons they're you know
it's difficult because you feel bad when
people come up and they hug you and they
say very nice things to you and they
want to exchange phone numbers with you
you know and you know that's it's it's
interesting I uh if it's just locally
here I'll meet people at my grocery
store and they'll say oh I know who you
are you know and I've ex with them I've
exchanged phone numbers and and I just
you know they're in right in the
community I don't worry too much about
it but if I'm traveling I it's a that's
a little awkward you know situation but
they'll send me text messages of their
ferments or whatever and that's nice you
know and then yes you know like Dr
Andrea said you you do get men who which
I find it very funny you know given that
I'm 65 years old you know who want to
marry you and I'll I'll have gentlemen
who live in other countries and they'll
say good thing we're an ocean apart
and uh that's probably a topic for a
whole nother I know we want to have you
back on the podcast in terms of of
practical tips I mean this is a real
prepare for Success that there's just
certain things that can come with being
known and being seen and and we didn't
really even have time to get into your
tips Mary about
um where you talk about you know don't
show the outside of your house or your
address like different practical things
so if you would love to learn more from
Mary's nest and Dr Andrea show them some
love in the comments hit the like button
if you've gotten value here in the
challenge group we still have a giveaway
Mel's going to come on in a bit we're
going to do some more things
um but I just want to acknowledge both
of you Mary I'm just so grateful for you
thanks for believing in Us in VRA early
on I mean and back in 2017 jumping in
but then putting in the work because yes
there's a system and yes there's
knowledge to learn but I just respect
your consistency and your hustle and
just the value you add to the world you
know I'm one of your subscribers and
I'll see your community tab friends at
Community tab posts and it always opens
with sweet friends you call everybody
hello sweet friends and the love that
you admit is real and you're helping
People's Health and their energy and all
these things that I love boosting your
immunity with turmeric and all you know
bone broth so you're just an absolute
inspiration to us and there's a lot of
love coming to you in the comments I
encourage you you know check those out
in Facebook and on YouTube later because
people just have incredible things to
say and then Dr Andrea literally with
repetitive strain injury and some carpal
tunnel like CIS symptoms I have watched
your videos too I'm in my home office so
our our bedroom is is across the hall
from here and we've got a TV in there
and I'll open up YouTube and I'll follow
along with exercises you put out into
the world and with your content and both
of you just are such incredible humans
if you're leveraging YouTube You're
Building you're in influence it's so
cool the benefits and the accolades but
you're just Mission driven and you're
Purpose Driven and so I'm so honored
that you take the time to pour into our
community
and that you would just be carrying the
torch that we hope uh that we've lit
here a little bit at think media we want
to help Purpose Driven people people
that are you know making great content
making a great living but also making a
major difference in the world and so Dr
Andrea thank you for all the good you're
doing you all already have the momentum
but your future is so bright we all got
to wear sunglasses you're gonna get that
gold play button Mary Dr Andrea you're
gonna be in a million it's a matter of
time like as you just stay consistent
and uh it's just so inspiring so thank
you for coming on today and
um we're going to jump into this next
part of our challenge think media
podcast uh subscribe if you're not
subscribed and click or tap the screen
because we just got the channel back and
so there's a new episode of the podcast
out that you can check out hit like if
you got value my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel